le sujet de départ je vais commencer
avec les choses frequency les fréquences
à j'aimerais vraiment pour le clip des
téléspectateurs à 21h41 qu'on fasse une
séquence qui restera mythique je suis
sûr dans la télévision française
j'aimerais voir une minute de
discussions entre jean claude van damme
et de jean alesi pas une minute vous
discuté on dit rien on dirait si j'ai
des patients typique l'assureur science
le sujet de départ je vais commencer
avec les choses frequency les fréquences
par exemple la fréquence humains non
c'est à dire donc si je te parle c'est
432 et shem et dans le téléphone c'est 4
4 4 ce qui donne le cancer d'ailleurs et
ça a été ça a été créé et inventé par
adolf hitler pour la propaganda non
ouais pendant la guerre oui la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est ça il y à il y
avait en entende et on émettait sur des
fréquences et toutes ces fréquences
elles sont restées ça veut dire que tu
peux entendre encore des gens dans
l'avion 20 énergie gmbh ap
attention est allé me fiscale
[Musique]
franchement je rajoute une minute alors
si à propos de fréquences
chaque specis animaux sur la terre
rennie spécisme ont des fréquences
différentes de communication ok donc il
faut pas oublier avec les iphone
intelligence comme ils connaissent
toutes les fréquences du monde entier
les gens qui disent que les computer ne
sont pas vivant et j'y crois pas
tellement avec un pétaflop est égale à
31 millions de penser une seconde est
des compétiteurs qui font entre 75
pétaflops à 125 comme ça où la confusion
les je sais j'en étais un million
d'équations x 175 pas de réponse alors
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pourrez
alors sonné en attendant qu'est ce que
vous répondez pour un sage en doc gynéco
en fait les ces fréquences elles sont
restées dans l'air a quittés mais vous
pouvez tu peut les entendre
elles sont c'est tout ce qu'ils ont émis
pendant cette période c'est resté comme
ça dans l'air ils l'entendent et grâce à
quoi
i au plasma à cela le place
[Applaudissements]
celle ci porte j jean claude jean cot et
ils sont très intelligents les deux eric
we can prononcée le gall m6 j'ai cru
qu'elle aborde maintenant mais je vais
changer de l'achat je vais très vite j à
13 ans j'ai vendu des fleurs j'ai fait
un peu d'argent et puis j'ai fait une
salle de sport et puis movistar
hollywood canada pendant sept ans qu'est
ce que j'ai fait
jour et nuit du matthew key l'éducation
de maintenant donc j'ai pas pris
adam f la pomme l'enfant
donc j'ai commencé dans les choses comme
queen century et des choses que les gens
pour l'instant m'ont pas aidé vue qui y
travaillent et n'ont pas le temps de
voir et d'apprendre les choses
aujourd'hui que toi tu connaisses way et
de là il ya eu toute la suisse
connaissez vous pas des noms mais les
super intéressant pas c'est vrai
[Musique]